olá prepare-se para conhecer os 10
sinais e sintomas de que seus rins estão
intoxicados para que você possam
identificar esses possíveis sinais de
falha renal a fim de reverter ou tratar
o quanto antes assim você nunca terá de
enfrentar a dura Estrada da
insuficiência renal diálise transplante
renal os rins são tão vitais que em caso
de falha grave você sentiria um malestar
significativa em poucos dias podendo
levar a um desfecho fatal rapidamente
hoje o meu propósito é l munir com a
capacidade de identificar essas
condições em seus estágios iniciais e
quais são Então os sinais e sintomas de
que seus rins estão com problemas o
sinal número um é quando a sua vitamina
D de dado está baixa no sangue pessoal
os rins ajudam na importante conversão
da vitamina D inativa na forma
sem un zins funcionando a pleno vapor a
vitamina D de dado permanece inutilizada
como um carro potente que não tem
gasolina Isso significa que não importa
a quantidade de vitamina D que você
consuma se os zins não estiverem fazendo
o seu trabalho não estiverem em boa
forma você não conseguirá transformar
essa vitamina D para Que ela possa
realmente ser utilizada e qual é a
consequência disso deficiência de
vitamina D O sinal número dois é quando
você sente a necessidade urinar fazer
xixi com mais frequência você acorda no
meio da noite com uma vontade súbita de
ir ao banheiro seus zins filtram e
removem as impurezas do corpo mas se
esses filtros estão danificados você
pode notar um aumento no desejo de
urinar pessoal Às vezes isso também pode
ser um sinal de infecção urinária ou
aumento da próstata nos homens o sinal
número três é quando você está sempre
cansado ou cansada tem menos energia ou
está tendo problemas para se concentrar
nesse caso os seus rins podem estar
enviando um sinal de SOS a Oria um
subproduto do metabolismo das proteínas
pode ser
aculada quando os hins estão
sobrecarregados a oreia se acumula no
sangue e o resultado é uma fadiga que
parece nunca ter fim além disso a doença
renal pode convidar um intruso
indesejado anemia isso pode aumentar
ainda mais a sensação de fraqueza e
fadiga o sintoma número quatro é quando
a sua pele começa a ficar seca ou com
coceira a coceira pode ser um indicativo
de problemas renais dos rins
Especialmente quando se trata de doença
renal crônica geralmente isso ocorre
devido ao acúmulo de toxinas no sangue
um sinal de que os rins estão com
dificuldade para cumprir a sua função
pessoal isoladamente a coceira e a pele
seca pode ser várias outras coisas pode
ser sintomas de outras condições de
saúde Ok o sintoma número cinco são um
conjunto de alterações na sua urina no
início da doença renal os sintomas podem
ser quase que invisíveis mas Fique
atento a mudanças sutis como alteração
na frequência na cor no cheiro da urina
ou até mesmo uma sensação de queimação
ao fazer xixi se você notar que sua
urina está muito descolorida turva ou
até mesmo espumosa isso pode ser um
sinal de que seus Ines estão pedindo
ajuda o sintoma número seis é quando
você está experimentando inchaço também
conhecido como edema nas pernas ou
embaixo dos olhos Imagine que seus
tornozelos e pés começam a enchar ou
aparece aquelas bolsas volumosas abaixo
dos seus olhos algo que você nunca t
Este não é um sinal de que você exagerou
na festa de aniversário de alguém mas
pode ser um sinal de que seus rins estão
passando por uma espécie de festa tóxica
quando você pressiona a parte inferior
da perna ou dos pés e a pele mantém o
amassado F aquele buraco isso é o edema
e se isso acontecer com você
constantemente seus rins podem estar
gritando por ajuda esse sintoma
especialmente nas duas as pernas ou nos
dois pés ou a redor dos olhos pode ser
um alerta importante paraa toxicidade
renal e o sinal número sete os seus
índices estariam tóxicos é quando você
está tendo problemas para dormir pessoal
quando os rins não estão filtrando
adequadamente as toxinas elas permanecem
no sangue em vez de deixar o corpo pelo
xixi isso pode dificultar muito sono há
também uma ligação importante da pnea do
sono porque ela é mais comum em pessoas
com doença renal crônica em comparação
com a população em geral o sintoma
número oito é a pressão alta a
hipertensão arterial é um sinal bem
comum de doença renal numa analogia
básica é como colocar muito peso em uma
mola delicada a pressão excessiva
danifica os minúsculos filtros nos seus
rins conhecido como glomérulos eles são
formados o ramos da artéria renal por
outro lado os rins desempenham um papel
crucial na manutenção da pressão
arterial eliminando o excesso de sal do
corpo se não eliminarem sal suficiente a
pressão arterial pode subir Sim se os
rins não estão funcionando direito não
estão funcionando bem a regulação da
pressão arterial pode estar comprometida
isso leva a pressão alta hipertensão e
suas consequências o sinal no é um gosto
metálico na boca hálito de amônia a
amônia é algo que você normalmente se
livra sai pelo xixi pela urina e como
seu corpo não está conseguindo se livrar
dela no caso vai até pelos pulmões
causando esse ma hálito E você também
pode sentir um gosto metálico à medida
que mais toxinas começam a se acumular
tentando deixar o seu corpo o sintoma
número 10 é o depósito de cristais de
ureia na pele se você perceber pequenas
manchas brancas na sua pele semelhantes
a uma fina camada de cristais ou neve
esse fenômeno é conhecido como geada
urêmica e consiste em cristalização da
ureia após a sua excreção pelo suor que
acaba se depositando na pele geralmente
no couro cabeludo ou na testa um grande
abraço e um caloroso beijo no seu
coração